hey everybody Dan here with Roth Spencer
and Joe to talk to you about some stuff
that you may have heard about answer
some questions let you know what's going
on here at screen junkies as you may or
may not have heard we are under new
ownership we have a new owner a place
called fandom fandom has acquired screen
junkies not just the name not just the
brand they have acquired the sets they
have acquired us they have acquired
these microphones they have acquired
this copy of Air Bud on VHS and the
Skeletor figure and they own that ant
farm anything that you've seen or heard
on screen junkies we are now part of
fandom so what does that mean right now
well it means that nothing really at the
moment nothing that you know or like
about screen Dougie's is gonna change
right now they're not coming in here and
cleaning house or they're not coming in
here and canceling everything basically
it is as happens anytime there is a
change of ownership there's gonna be a
transition period but while we're
working through that everything you know
and love is gonna be right here we're
gonna be doing the same shows we're
gonna be doing it at the same time we're
gonna be on these same sets for at least
a while and so everything that you know
and love even this this space store to
my left that no one ever sees on camera
because it was put somewhere that would
never be shot it's a really cool and
farms right now nothing is gonna change
because phantom is really invested and
real really invested in working with
them on figuring out new opportunities
without completely upsetting the
applecart as it is right now plus ruff
the thing that we're really worried
about is comic-con which is less than 30
days away we're you I know or right in
the middle of spearheading the effort to
plan that that's what where our focus is
so you know if you're worried that
things are gonna change and tomorrow
you're gonna turn out screen junkies is
gonna be something completely new that's
not what's gonna happen yeah we are full
steam ahead on Comic Con we're actually
gonna do some fun stuff there with
fandoms so we'll start to see what that
looks like then and also the question
might be why why why I won
my question why oh good question job
thank you for asking well a lot of it is
kind of like business paper bla bla bla
captain business unikitty but that is we
always want to grow and in conversations
it just felt like phantom was a really
really good fit for us they are one of
the biggest and Spencer's going to get
into this a little bit but they are one
of the biggest gaming TV and movie sites
in the world and we're one of the
biggest YouTube channel thanks to these
gentlemen right here
that sounds so bratty but I guess it's
true who's bigger ruff actually probably
some people I could name a bunch right
now but I won't like gaming whatever
it's not a contest um it's not a contest
this is a very good fan would come a
name we go together the way the good
things do like raptors and doors jo jte
and Sylvester Stallone a Patrick Swayze
and Jeff Goldblum arm wrestling in
backwards hats yeah very well together
and we go well with phantom and the
reason is is because we you know we love
the fact that people have their
individual passions in life we were
having a conversation about this earlier
today I know somebody that's obsessed
with the movie Midnight Cowboy and has
literally recreated half of the movie in
models people have their individual
fandoms and we celebrate fun aside and
that's what fandom is all about it's
where you can go to find the people and
the communities that love the things
that you do that's sort of what we have
done with each other here at screen
jockeys yeah when I heard the news I
would because I didn't know what fandom
was and then when I looked it up I went
of course I know those people they're
wikia they're Wikipedia then the Marvel
database there they've changed their
name to fandom but they have like every
nerd or pop culture beyond community
website where it's all fan run and
there's edited pieces there's editorials
they have so much cool stuff up there
anytime you're googling like I don't
know what's something you'd Google does
anything Doctor Who okay I wouldn't I
would know them however like the first
time you were watching Game of Thrones
you guys probably went who is the night
came yes there's guy that is always like
the first thing that shows up I've been
on their websites hundreds of times for
honest trailers like the maybe Australis
will be there too someday your buddy
Jacob insists that they're called tremor
monsters and not graboids and you're
like all right let's let's settle this
that's where you go so it's been a year
for us it's it's it's been a year but uh
we wanted to take a second to to just
say thank you for continuing to stick
with us this year has been a lot of
changes a lot of stuff going on but what
remains consistent is the fact that we
get to kind of come here every day and
hang out with you guys
means a lot to us and it only happens
because you are on the other end hanging
out with us and watching the shows every
day so let us know what you kind of
think blow in the comments hit us on
Twitter ask questions we might have
answers here from you and we'll know
what you're thinking about yeah exactly
exactly and if everybody keeps asking
the same questions and we'll go in
search of answers for those at the very
least at the very least we can promise
you that so we'll see you guys
completely unchanged with skeletor's
space tour and ant farm tomorrow morning